hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute gibt es mal ein ganz
neues rezept und zwar gibt es heute
einen blueberry mit streuseln obendrauf
und tischen ziemlich schnelles rezept
denn die streusel werden aus dem teig
gemacht also das heißt ich muss nur
einen tag machen und habe später den
boden und auch die streusel obendrauf zu
dieser jahreszeit gibt es natürlich
keine frischen heidel werden deswegen
nehme ich jetzt tiefgekühlte heidberg
und ich zeige euch einfach mal kurz die
zutaten also hier habe ich die
heidelbeeren bis 600 gramm 500 gramm
davon habe ich so ein bisschen auftauen
lassen und 100 gramm sie noch richtig
gefroren
dann habe ich hier 50 gramm zucker da
könnte auch mehr oder weniger nehmen je
nachdem wie süß die heidelbeeren sind
dann brauchen wir den saft und die
schale einer limette oder einer zitrone
aber ich finde die mitte passt besser
und 30 g speisestärke dessen jetzt die
zutaten für die füllung und jetzt kommen
die zutaten für den teig und zwar habe
ich 250 gramm mehl 125 gramm butter die
habe ich schon verlassen
hier sind 70 gramm zucker und dann
brauche ich nur 100 gramm haferflocken
business kernigen haferflocken 50 gramm
mandeln das herz gestiftete könnte aber
auch andere nüsse nehmen oder irgendwas
was ich eben gut schmeckt und hier noch
ein esslöffel brauner zucker sally warum
zerlassene butter
ja denn ich werde jetzt gleich den tag
vorbereiten und dann geht es einfach
eben viel einfacher also es hat nichts
mit dem zug und irgendwie mit das muss
um ins verlassene mutter kann man auch
ein wenig butter stück rain wird es geht
eben dann bessern wird der teig ebene zu
trocken und man kann einfach die butter
besser verteilen
aber bevor ich jetzt den teig zubereitet
gehe ich an meinen kopf denn ich muss
jetzt die blaubeeren erstmals den
aufkochen und da nehme ich jetzt die 500
gramm die eben gefroren die eben
aufgetaut sind es ist ein amerikanisches
rezept oder ja ok
da gibt es immer bleiben damit
amerikanische rezepte findet immer dazu
gehalts nicht hoch genau den habe ich
halt reduziert auf deutsche standards
sage ich jetzt mal so gebe es da die
schale der limette dazu läuft einfach
wichtig dass ihr da jetzt keine
behandelt limette habe sondern eine bio
limette die muss man natürlich vorher
auch gut abwaschen und das sorgt jetzt
für das leckere zitronige aroma jetzt
nehme ich die limette und drückst du so
ein bisschen mit der hand zusammen dann
kommt nämlich mehr saft raus und dann
plötzlich da als noch den saft rein
und jetzt kommt da noch der zucker mit
rein ich gebe ihnen jetzt komplett mit
rein denn die waren nicht so sehr süß
und dann auch noch die speisestärke die
sorgt jetzt gleich für die bindung damit
es ganz ähnlich flüssig sondern das fest
wird
und jetzt versuche ich das einfach ganz
kurz und zeitgleich dem herz auf höchste
stufe und dass es so einfach 23 minuten
lang kochen
ich habe es jetzt gar nicht zwei minuten
aufkochen lassen denn sie sind schon
nach dem aufkochen direkt fest und jetzt
gebe ich noch die gefrorenen heidel
werden wir dazu denn dann kühlt dieser
masse gleich schnell ab und da waren
stock mit drin
zieht man handgeld die gerade noch
gepflückt an 60 teilnehmer natürlich
raus und jetzt höre ich die hier kurz
ein und lass es dann einfach an der
seite stehen damit eben abkühlen kann
und in der zwischenzeit bereitet jetzt
schon mal den teig vor und für den boden
brauchen wir jetzt einfach das mehl dann
den zucker die butter und das berühre
ich jetzt hier kurz und ihr seht auch er
sprach dafür keine küchenmaschine es
geht einfach alles so mit einem löffel
oder eben mit so einem silikon werkzeuge
mit so einem schaber einfach alles
verrühren
schon richtig schnelles rezept und vor
allem kammer diesen kuchen richtig gut
vorbereiten
und jetzt habe ich hier so eine tat form
und zwar kann man hier den boden
herausheben
das heißt wenn ich das jetzt gleich
darin mache kann ich später bösen paar
einfach ausleben ohne dass er eben
kaputt geht
ihr könnt ganz aber auch zum beispiel in
einer springform machen die hier hat
jetzt so etwa 22 bis 24 zentimeter im
durchmesser und die hat seine
antihaftbeschichtung aber ich werde
trotzdem mit dem bug trendline einfach
um sicherzugehen dass da eben nichts an
klebt es vorbei geschützt macht aber nix
jetzt nehme ich zwei drittel von meinem
tag also lasst so etwa ein drittel übrig
und gibt es da rein und dann drücken
wird es gleich ans boden an
so sollte das reichen jetzt nehmen da
hat einfach wieder den löffel und könnte
es an drücken wie bisschen traurig und
könnte auch einfach die finger nehmen
und am rand ebenso ein rand hochziehen
und willi dass ein bisschen mehr bindung
mit drin haben wollt könnt auch gerne
geld mit rein geben dann ist das nicht
so ganz bröselig sondern er gebunden
aber wir wollen einfach kein eigelb in
unserem in unseren streuseln haben die
sollen nämlich richtig gruselig sein
aber man ist hier so richtig fest
andrücken und später einfach vorsichtig
schneidet dann klappt es auch nicht so
gut
und wenn es dann richtig gut an gedrückt
habt können die blaue band schon mit
drauf und guck mal was das für eine
tolle farbe ist
zum richtig dunkles lila rot
jetzt nehme ich mir einfach die
restlichen streusel gibt da noch
haferflocken mit rein
die schmeckt nämlich richtig gut wenn
man sie in streuseln verarbeitet und die
mandeln und den zucker nämlich später um
ihn dann drüber zu streuen so dass wir
möchten jetzt einfach mit meinen händen
weil es einfach schneller geht
und dann gebe ich das da oben drauf
bei mir passen dass nicht alle straßen
drauf ich glaube ich habe ein bisschen
zu viel haferflocken drin aber ich lass
das jetzt einfach so morgenhorn zweiten
und jetzt nehme ich den zucker und
streut den ochtruper dann kann es
nämlich im ofen so ein bisschen
karamellisieren
all das geht so schnell oder ja alles
gebraucht ich zu dick geguckt also
bisher so 15 minuten und die den blue
berry gebe ich jetzt mit sauberen händen
gleich bei 175 grad für etwa 25 bis 30
minuten in den ofen
die oberfläche ist und einfach ein
bisschen gold braucht sein und dann
sehen darin gleich wenn er wieder
rauskommt
ein paar setzt abgekühlt und ich hole
jetzt aus der form raus und jetzt jetzt
auch wieso so wichtig ist dass man eben
entweder eine springform nimmt oder eine
plattform mit seinem heber boden
denn sonst kriegt man das echt nicht aus
der form raus bist du da oben da klingt
jetzt wissen dass glaube
setzt sich das auf eine tortenplatte und
nehmen aber diesen springform boten
unten einfach weg aber mit einem messer
drunter
sound
und ich hätte jetzt den boden des
teiches als ich hier so einfach so
wissel hört sie müssen dann wäre auch
von den blauen band nichts drüber
gelaufen aber ich finde es jetzt auch
gar nicht schlimm ich dazu jetzt so ein
bisschen geschlagene sahne die habe ich
hier bereits vorbereitet einfach sahne
steif geschlagen ohne zucker ohne
irgendwas denn ich denke dass der kuchen
einfach schon süß genug ist jetzt
schneiden wir immer zusammen an
übrigens gibt es sehr verschiedene
möglichkeiten um so weit zu machen
also es gibt ja auch die möglichkeit
dass nur so eine tagschicht darüber hat
und da zum beispiel herzchen aussprechen
kann oder man legt den teig als gitta
oben drauf und es ist jetzt einfach so
eine variante mit streuseln
was nächsten halt immer wieder sauber
und dann reicht ihr dazu einfach so
einen löffel sahne obendrauf oder nicht
so ganz knapp neben dran
magst du probieren
eine gabel und ich denke das wird es
gleich so eine geschmacksexplosion im
mund
diese dieser crunch obendrauf säuerlich
süße blaubeeren und gut das schmeckt so
lecker wenn man sich auf weißt du sagst
diese schicht dann schmieden sie recht
säuerlich und die sahne
genauso habe ich eine vorgestellt so ein
richtig rundes so richtig hundekuchen
also schöner knackiger boden schön mürbe
wahrscheinlich auch dann die früchte
innen drin und dann eben die straßen
obendrauf
ich kann mir jetzt auch gleich ein
stückchen aber ihr dürft gleich das
rezept auf meinem blog nachlesen auf cds
blog.de
da gibt es die ganze anleitung auch
nochmal zum ausdrucken und wir schießen
gleich noch ein foto für instagram denn
da könnt ihr mir auch folgen und werde
ihnen dieses paar jahre danach macht
kannst mir auch gerne schicken auf
facebook oder instagram da freue ich
mich immer drüber ich schaue mir auch
immer meistens alle bilder und alle
kommentare an kann nur nicht immer alle
sofort beantworten
aber ich gebe mir auf jeden fall ganz
viel mühe ja ich würde sagen uns im
guten appetit euch noch viel spaß und
wir sehen uns das nächste mal wieder bis
bald